SPEAKER: Optimizing
GKE clusters for cost
is not a one-time exercise.
It's a longer journey to shift
team and organizational culture
while incrementally
implementing best practices.
One of these best practices
is to use monitoring systems
specific to GKE to
help establish cost
optimization as a discipline.
Let's take a look at
why we should do this
and how it can be done.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
As you may have seen in
previous videos from the series,
there are a handful
of critical areas
to practice cost optimization
in a GKE environment.
We'll focus on
three of these areas
and how they fit into a
monitoring system for cost
optimization, specifically
culture, bin packing, and app
right-sizing.
Let's start by
discussing culture.
Teams who own GKE
environments are not simply
trying to drive down costs
while ignoring everything else.
They instead must balance
cost-saving techniques
while ensuring the
applications running on GKE
are still performant, stable,
and continue to deliver value
to their users.
To effectively
balance all of this,
teams have begun incorporating
cloud financial management,
or FinOps, into their culture.
This is the practice of
building systems for financial
accountability in the
pay-as-you-go cloud world.
Now, put this into the
context of Kubernetes.
Rapid adoption of
Kubernetes in particular
means that many teams are
still learning and establishing
their own best practices.
This is true when
it comes to managing
the cost of running
their clusters,
especially as they grow.
Continuous monitoring
of these environments
enables the necessary
cultural shift.
When teams have proper tuning
and data at their disposal
to practice cost
optimization, the awareness
shifts the discipline earlier
in the software development
lifecycle.
So what specifically
should we aim
to accomplish with
monitoring here?
First, we'll want to
focus on a cluster
administrator-centric
monitoring system.
We can do so with a focus
on cluster bin packing.
Bin packing is the ability to
effectively schedule workloads
across nodes in a cluster, in
such a way that ensures there
are little wasted resources--
CPU and memory, for example.
Efficient bin
packing is achieved
with a real-time understanding
of how much resources workloads
request, and how
those workloads fit
into the various amounts
of allocatable resources
that the VMs and the
cluster have available.
Cluster administrators,
when empowered
with the right
monitoring data, can
improve how they support
cluster tenants, while also
ensuring that provision
infrastructure is not wasted.
We can even set up
alerting policies
on the data collected for
the most egregious cases
of overprovisioning to
proactively kick off
the process of
cost optimization.
Developers can also benefit
from a different perspective--
a monitoring system that
captures recommendations
for app right-sizing.
This enables developers
to better understand
how much of the
requested resources
are actually being utilized
by their application.
With a deep understanding
of scenarios
where they may be
overprovisioned
in their workload
requests, developers
can make informed
decisions on how
they can easily reduce cost.
Now that we've looked at
the importance of culture,
bin packing, and app
right-sizing for GKE cost
optimization, the next
step is setting up
the monitoring system.
Be sure to check out the paper
linked in the description.
We publish an
end-to-end guide on how
you can set up such a monitoring
system with Google Cloud
Monitoring.
In the next video, we'll cover
how cluster administrators can
set up monitoring for
cluster bin packing
to optimize costs on GKE.
Stay tuned.
[MUSIC PLAYING]